>>presenter: Hello, everyone.
>>audience: Hello!
>>presenter: Thank you
very much for coming today.
This is actually the
first time I've
hosted a Musicians@Google
event, so bear with me.
I'm a little bit nervous, but
I could not be happier to
have the honor of
introducing today's guest.
We're incredibly fortunate to
have him with us today for
an acoustic performance and
he'll be sticking around
for a bit to answer
your questions after,
after the show.
So, you can submit questions
or you can vote on questions
at go/askfranti, alright?
Michael has been well known to
area music fans for well over
20 years and has earned a
truly international following
during that time.
He's built a reputation for
tremendously energetic and
positive performances that
often combine sharp social
commentary with a fusion
of countless musical styles
including, but absolutely
not limited to reggae,
hip-hop, rock, folk, jazz,
and if you listen closely,
even a few metal
riffs here and there.
Michael and his band, Spearhead,
are perhaps best known
to San Franciscans and Bay
Area natives in general,
for their Power to the
Peaceful Festival,
which is a free event
that draws tens of
thousands to Golden Gate Park
each year for two magical days
in music, and
social awareness.
They've been a fixture
on the national fe-,
festival scene as well,
with appearances at Bonnaroo,
Coachella, the Taos
Solar Music Festival
and the New Orleans Jazz
Fest, just to name a few.
Michael and Spearhead are
currently touring in support
of their forthcoming
album, The Sound of Sunshine,
which will be released
on August 24th
and he'll be appearing
here in the Bay Area
at the Greek Theatre in
Berkeley on July 16th.
So, on behalf of
mu-, Musicians@Google,
it is my great pleasure to
welcome Mr. Michael
Franti to the stage.
[applause and clapping]
[whistle]
>>Franti: Thanks so much
for having us here today
and I brought my buddy, Jay,
with me to play guitar.
Jolene here to sing with us and
my son is here, Ade, and--
[clapping]
[guitar strumming]
it's a big part of his summer
vacation to be out here.
[guitar strumming]
And I'll play a couple songs.
Then I guess we'll do some,
some questioning and answering.
But I've always thought that
it would be really cool to
do shows where instead of the
people asking the performers,
[uses deep voice] "Would
you please turn off
your cell phone or devices?"
That it would be the
opposite; that at our shows
people would go there and
they'd turn on their phones
and they'd use their phone
interactively during the show,
so please feel free to type
away [laughs] at your computer
or take pictures or film or
blog or vlog or if you wanna
come up here and sing and
film it while we're doin' it--
[audience laughs]
or do a dance behind us,
or like, [strums guitar]
anyway, here we go.
One, two, three, come on.
[upbeat guitar music]
Put your hand together, ya'll.
"I wake up in the
morning its six o'clock
They say there may be
rain but the sun is hot
I wish I had some time
just to kill today
And I wish I had a dime for
every bill I got to pay
Some days you lose you win
And the water's as high
as the times you're in
So I just back in where
I learned to swim
Try to keep my head
above it the best I can
That's why, here I am, waitin'
for this storm to pass me by
That's the sound of
sunshine comin' down
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay"
One, two, put your
hands together now
"I saw my friend Bobby.
He said 'what's up man.
You got a little work or 20
to lend' I opened up my hand
he said 'I'm glad to see
They can take away my job
but not my friends.'
You see and here I am, waitin'
for this storm to pass me by
That's the sound of
sunshine comin' down
sunshine comin' down"
Google, tell me how
you feelin' y'all
"I wanna go where the
summer never ends
With my guitar on the beach
there with all my friends
The sun's so hot and
the wave's in motion
And everything smells
like suntan lotion
The ocean and the
girls so sweet
So kick off your shoes
and relax your feet
They say that miracles
are never ceasin'
Every single soul needs
a little releasin'
Stereo bumpin' till
the sun goes down
And I only wanna
hear that sound
That's the sound of
sunshine comin' down
Yeah, that's the sound
of sunshine comin' down"
Boogie rock that guitar
[guitar solo]
Give it up for Jake Boogie
on the guitar, ya'll
"You're the one I wanna be with
When the sun goes down
You're the one I wanna be with
When the sun goes
That's the sound of
sunshine comin' down"
There you go
"That's the sound of
sunshine comin' down
Ay ay ay ay ay ay ay
Ay ay ay ay ay ay ay"
I wanna hear ya'll sing it now
"That's the sound of
[mouths the words] sunshine
comin' down"
[applause]
A little louder.
[sings] "That's
[mouths the words] the
sound of sunshine comin' down
[sings] Yeeeeaaaaaah!"
[fast guitar strumming]
The Google Tabernacle Choir
in attendance.
[laughter and applause]
All right.
[more upbeat guitar music]
"Oh you're perfect just the way
you are, just the way you are
Oh you're perfect just the way
Shake it, shake it,
shake it - come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me
Shake it, shake it,
shake it - come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me now
Shake it, shake it mama,
you the one for me
I'm realizin you the only
one that's meant to be
And when I wake up in the
mornin' all I wanna see
Is the sun that is shinin
on you next to me
You got a little broken nail,
got a hair outta place
A little bit of extra middle
right around the waist
With all of them things
I never ever hesitate
'Cause the thing about you baby
is the smile on your face
Blowin' kisses at you girl,
I hope they didn't miss
The way you move your body made
it hard for them to hit you
I wish you would come
a little closer
Rub a little closer mama
See it mama closer
So shake it, shake it,
shake it - come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me
Shake it, shake it,
shake it, come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me now
Shake it, shake it, shake it
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me
Shake it, shake it, shake it"
How you feelin', ya'll?
"I got love for you baby,
never givin it up
I love the way you love me,
never gettin enough
I love the way you shake that
little extra bit of butta
When I see you move your body,
girl it makes my heart a flutta
When I see you dance upon
the living room floor,
on the kitchen table
Better open up the door
Bring the party to the street
because the street
will love her more
The people love the beat, and
the beat will love her more
With the music blastin,
the people clappin,
the speakers shakin,
the kids will take it
You're perfect, just
the way you are -
you're perfect just
the way you are
Shake it, shake it,
shake it - come mama
Shake it, shake it shake it,
you the one for me
Shake it, shake it,
shake it - come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me now
Shake it, shake it, shake it
Shake it, shake it,
shake it- come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it
I said, oh, you're perfect
just the way you are,
just the way you are
Oh, you're perfect
just the way you are,
just the way you are
Oh, just the way you are,
Oh, just the way you are."
[guitar strumming] We need some
volunteers from the audience.
All right, come
on up here, man.
Come on up here.
Come on up here, come on now.
[guitar strumming]
What's your name?
>>David: David.
>>Franti: Give it up for David.
>>David: I went to UC Davis.
[guitar strumming]
>>Franti: You went to UC Davis?
Nice.
David from Davis.
I grew up in Davis.
All right, we got a
lot of volunteers here.
Ok, we're gonna have
a shake it contest.
David, you're first.
Don't go to the back,
man, come back up here.
Come on, "shake it,
shake it, shake it."
Put your hands together.
"Shake it, shake it, shake it.
You the one for me now.
Shake it,
shake it, shake it
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me now.
Shake it, shake it, shake it
Shake it, shake it, shake it."
Give it up for that fine
YouTube moment from David,
y'all!
Eric.
This is Eric with
some interpretive dance.
[guitar] Woooo!
Give it up for Eric, ya'll.
Ok, we gotta make this a
little more difficult.
What's your name?
This is Heather.
Give it up for Heather.
This is Heather doing
the California condor,
the rare, endangered
species at a NASCAR event.
The California
condor at a NASCAR event.
[laughter] NASCAR
is auto racing.
Ok, ready?
Here we go.
[guitar] [hoots and hollers
from audience]
Give it up for Heather.
Ok, we got my son.
My son, Ade, doing
the robot at Google.
[guitar]
Give it up for Ade!
[applause]
All right, we got one
more person over here.
What's your name?
Give it up for Hillary.
>>Hillary: Be nice.
>>Franti: She said be nice.
Ok, anybody have a,
something for Hillary
to interpretive dance?
What?
>>member1: The Macarena.
>>Franti: The Macarena!
[resumes guitar strumming]
[sings] "One Maca, two Maca,
three Macarena, four Maca,
five Maca, six Macarena
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na
Hey Macarena"
[guitar]
Obviously, she's been
taking lessons at the,
at the Google "How to be Cool
at a Party Dance Class, right?
All right.
[sings] "So shake it
on the beach girl,
vamos a la playa
Hotter than the sun,
you know you set
the soul on fiya
A bird in the sky, you make
me feel like a flier -
higher, higher, higher, higher
I got love for you baby,
like every single
day Love for you,
in every single way
I got love for you,
and everything that I cook
It's not the way that you look,
it's the way that you shook
Everybody, shake it, shake
it, shake it- come mama
Shake it, shake it,
shake it- come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me now
Shake it, shake it,
shake it- come mama
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me
Shake it, shake it,
shake it, woohoo
Shake it, shake it, shake it,
you the one for me
Shake it, shake it, shake it
Shake it, shake it, shake it"
Give it up for them, ya'll.
Eric, David, Sue,
Hillary, Sara, Ade.
Thanks, ya'll.
[applause] Awesome, David.
[pause]
Ok.
[pause] That was a
nice little warm up.
I like that dude back there.
He's got a lot of energy.
What department are you in?
>>member2: Security.
>>Franti: Aaah!
No wonder.
Hahaha.
Ok, questions, right?
Is that what we're doin' now?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I'd love some water.
[pause] Does
anybody have a question?
>>memberfemale3: Will
you please sing more?
>>Franti: What's that?
>>memberfemale3: Will
you please sing more?
[laughter] >>Franti: Oh,
yeah we'll sing more, yeah?
Are we supposed
to do questions?
Is that this works?
Oh, we mix it up.
Ok, we'll take a question.
Anybody have a question?
Ok.
>>member4: What's it
like opening for Mayer?
>>Franti: What is it
[pause] Mayor
McCheese or John Mayer?
[laughter]
Oh. John Mayer.
It was really a
unique experience
because right when
we started the tour,
he had this big
article come out in,
I guess, Playboy magazine,
which I never read, of course.
[laughter] And, you know, he
said all these flammatory,
inflammatory things, very, you
know, weird stuff, you know?
Sexual and racial things and
so I immediately went to him
and talked to him about
it and at the time
he was super remorseful,
you know what I mean?
He was just like, he said, "This
is the worst day of my life.
I don't know how it
could get any worse."
And so we talked
for a long time.
We actually became really
good friends around it,
you know?
And my music has
always been the opposite,
you know?
To try to bring people,
different groups together
and he, his music is that, too.
But, sometimes his mouth
runs in a different way.
[laughter] And so, we
just talked a lot about
getting your heart
and your mouth to
say what you mean and mean
what you say, you know?
And so we had a really great
time and it was really cool
cause we recorded
this new album,
"Sound of Sunshine," in
the dressing room of
all these locker rooms of
the NBA and hockey teams
that we were playing in.
And so, you know, we'd go out
on stage and we'd play a song
to 15,000 people who had
never heard our music before
and then we'd go in the locker
room afterwards and we'd say,
"You know, we played that
one too fast or too slow."
And then we were
able to just like,
on our laptop,
re-record the song.
We'd set the drums up
in the shower and
I'd sing in the shower, which
is the best place to sing,
of course, and, and we made
this whole album on tour.
And so it was really great
to have that kind of like,
interactive capability
to be able to see
what the audience wants
or is responding to,
and then be able to go in
and just make
immediate changes.
And it used to be, they used
to make an album for months
or spend a year doing it
and then you get on the road
and you'd realize like, "God,
this song was too slow."
And, and so it was a
great experience for us to,
to be able to have
that huge audience
to see how people
respond, so yeah.
And in the end, me and
John became great buddies
and we had a fun time.
Yeah, thank you, man.
Thanks.
>>presenter: So, so we
have the Q&A mic here.
I thought I'd,
I'd cue things up.
Tell me more about
your, your YouTube story.
You were one of
the first artists
to really use that medium.
How did you get started
and what's it doin'
for you right now?
>>Franti: Well, I got started
through my son, Ade.
[audience member says Woo!]
[mild clapping]
Who was like, yeah, who really
got me excited about YouTube,
you know?
We'd stay up at
night and we'd be like,
"Ok, David Blaine."
[laughter] I mean, like,
YouTube David Blaine
for six hours, you know?
And then it would be like,
the best soccer goals of 2004,
you know, and-- [laughter]
and I'm still that way.
I don't have TV
per se in my house,
but I have YouTube and
I have Google and so,
we just, that's our way
of entertaining ourselves.
But I thought, "Wouldn't it be
cool to give people a little
glimpse of what we do
every day on tour."
Because I remember just
lookin' at album covers
when I was a kid and I'd see
like, a photo of The Clash
on this album and
I'd think like,
"Man, where did that
dude get his belt?"
Or where, where
did they, you know,
how does he string his
guitar backwards like that
or something and,
and so I thought,
"Wouldn't it be cool if like,
next time I went belt shopping
I just brought my
little camera with me
and we could show that."
So, we created this thing
called, "Fran TV,"
and every day we just do like
a two or three minute vlog
about our life on tour.
And sometimes
it's as, you know,
mundane as belt shopping
and other times
we're interviewing somebody
who is doing some really
creative grass roots
political organizing
or somebody who has got
a fantastic new record
or, that no one has ever heard
of and we interview them
or us just playing out on
the street somewhere.
So, we love YouTube.
>>membermale5: You just
mentioned some of the ways
that technology, including
technology created by Google,
is helping connect you to
the, the world of individuals.
What are some of the negative
sides of big companies
like Google, and what can
we do to mitigate those?
>>Franti: Hmmmm.
Negative things.
You know, I-, I'll,
I'll kinda say it in,
what, what people, what
some artists view
as a negative is obviously
downloading, you know?
And it's really
changed the music business,
the way that we do it.
I was one of the artists who
never really sold lots of
records, so when our music
started get downloaded
and traded, it, like
our career mushroomed.
It was the opposite and we
always made music for people
to enjoy and we hoped that
they would come to our shows
and then that they
would buy a t-shirt,
or that they would support us
by coming to 2, 3 or 4 shows.
And that's the way our
fan base grew and so,
we've always been
a band that said,
"Let's just ride with
the wave of technology;
whatever is coming out.
Let's use it to help spread
the word about what we do."
And we believe that if you
treat the fans with dignity
and love and connection, and
if they have a request that
you try your
best to fulfill it,
that they always come back.
And, and so, I don't really see
that there's anything wrong.
I can't think of
anything particularly
with Google that's wrong.
But just, you know, there's,
there's so many changes
that are, that are happening
as we speak in terms of
what music is delivered to
people and we're just a band
that feels like rather
than try to fight it
with lawyers and Congress
and all this kind of stuff,
that we just go with it
and see how we can change what
we do and get our head wrapped
around it in a different way
in a new way to help our fans
have the music because that's
the most important thing.
[pause] >>membermale6: If
Meg Whitman is elected
in November, who do you
think should do the next
California Uber Alles?
>>Franti: Oh, wow,
probably Woody Harrelson.
[laughter] Because, California
Uber Alles is this Dead
Kennedy's song that was about
the governor of California
back when, I think he wrote it
when Reagan was the governor
and then I did a version
when Pete Wilson was governor.
But, yeah, you know, I think
Woody would be a great person
because he's got a
great sense of humor
and he also smokes
loads of weed and--
[laughter] she's kind of;
she's kind of contrary to
either of those things.
[Franti laughs] So,
he'd be a good person.
[laughter]
>>Jolene: [inaudible]
>>Franti: Oh, sorry.
There's a monitor there.
[reads from monitor]
"What project, music
or otherwise, had the
biggest personal impact?
Which one has had the
most public impact?"
I presume they
mean of my work.
What project,
music or otherwise,
has had the
biggest personal impact?
[woman clears throat] Well,
my music always comes from
personal experience, but a
few years ago I took a trip to
Iraq and I played music
on the street and I was,
I kept watching the nightly news
and I kept watching YouTube.
And the things that I was
seeing on the nightly news
were completely the opposite of
what I was seeing on YouTube
in terms of what was happening
on the ground in Iraq.
And so I said to myself, "I'd
really like to go to Iraq
and see what's happened."
So, I took my guitar and
a video camera and 6 fr-,
and 6 friends and we
flew to Amman, Jordan.
We hopped in a 16 passenger
plane and we flew to Bagdad
and we get over the
airport in Bagdad
and the pilot says, "In order
to avoid a hit from a SAM-7
surface to air shoulder-launched
missile, or small arms fire
from the ground, we will enter
into a spiral descent."
[laughter] I was like, "I
don't know what all that
first stuff meant, but I
know what a spiral is."
[laughs] And sure enough,
we go into this descent
just spiraling straight
down to the ground
so he can get down there
as fast as possible
and a heat-seeking missile can
only make one arc, I found out.
So, if you keep
spinning, it can't hit you.
So I get on the ground
and I played music there
and I had all these songs
prepared that were, like,
you know, peace songs and
kind of protest songs
that I had written over the
years and I was gonna sing them
for people on the ground.
And when I got there,
I found that people,
Iraqis, were like, "That's
a really nice sentiment,
but play us something
that makes us dance.
Play us something
that makes us laugh.
that makes us smile,
or cry, or feel something."
And, and so it really changed
the way that I thought about
music cause the whole first
part of my career in music,
I wrote lots of really
heavy, political songs
and then I realized that if
I wanted to reach people
all over the place, i-, it's
like, you can either teach him,
give a man a fish, or teach
a man to fish, you know?
And that's what
I wanted to do.
I, I didn't just want to tell
people about one specific
issue, or tell somebody that one
certain person was good or bad,
I wanted to open
people's hearts so that
whatever they viewed in the
world, whatever issue it was,
that they had an open
heart and an open mind
to the perspective on it.
And, so that, that was a
really big change in the way
that I write music.
And so, instead of
writing political songs,
I write songs about whatever
I feel and then I go to those
places that I see there's
conflict and I play them
on the streets, and make films
about it and then I go back
and share what I've learned
with people in America
and other places
around the world.
[applause]
[pause]
All right, let's
play another song.
[clapping]
[guitar strumming]
This is a song -- last
summer, I was on tour
and my appendix ruptured
in the middle of the tour
and I was in the hospital
and every day I would,
you know, I'd go to the
window and I'd look to see
if the sun was
shining, you know?
And I'd pull the
curtain and I'd be like,
"Is the sun shining?"
And if it was, I'd
feel like, "Ahh, yes!
It's gonna be a great day
today and I'm gonna heal up."
And if the sun wasn't shining,
I'd then pull the covers over
my head and I'd try to imagine
someplace that was sunny,
you know?
Or I'd pick up a
guitar and I'd play
and I'd try to make sunshine
come out of the guitar and
my friends would make me laugh
and my stitches would bust open
and that would make me
laugh more, you know?
And so, I made this
whole record,
"The Sound of Sunshine,"
is all songs about
overcoming adversity and so,
this is one of those songs.
[guitar strumming]
[sings with guitar]
"It's been a long time
coming that I had to say
When I wake up in the
morning all I do is pray
For some guidance and
protection on the streets today
And an answer to the
questions I ask everyday
So tell me why do the birds
that used to fly here
Tell me why do they
come to die here
And all the kids that
used to run here
Tell me why do they load
their guns here I remember,
in the days when we were
one heart no need to defend
I just wrap my arms around you
Don't give up
This song is for you
Hey, hey, hey, no matter
how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another
moment slip away
I say hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another
moment slip away
I hold on, I'm tryin'
to hold on,
I hold on,
hold on, hold on
From the tops of the buildings
to the streets below
From the Wall Street
banks to the empty homes
Between the lines of the
people standing all in a row
There's a crack in the
gutter where a flower grows
Remindin' me that
everything is possible
Yeah remindin' me that
nothing is impossible
You gotta live for the one
that you love you know
You gotta love for the life
that you live you know
Singin' hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another
moment slip away
I say hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another
moment slip away
I hold on, I'm
tryin' to hold on,
I hold on, I'm tryin' to hold on
Until the morning comes again,
I will remain with
you my friend
We will dance
until the sun goes to
the place where it begun
We will live to laugh
and cry another day
Don't let nobody ever tell
you that it couldn't be done
you that we couldn't be one
Don't let nobody ever tell you
that it shouldn't be sung
Don't let nobody ever tell
you you're the only one
[applause, cheers]
Singin' hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another
moment slip away
I say hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say"
Put your hands up high, ya'll
"Woah oh oh oh Woah oh oh oh
Woah oh oh oh Woah oh oh oh,
I'm just tryin' to hold on
Tryin' to hold on
I say hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another
moment slip away
I say hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another
moment slip away
hold on, I'm
tryin' to hold on,
[audience clapping in rhythm]
hold on, hold on, hold on
Don't let nobody ever tell
you that it couldn't be done
you that we couldn't be one
Don't let nobody ever tell you
that it shouldn't be sung
Don't let nobody ever tell
you you're the only one
Singin' hey, hey, hey, no
matter how life is today
There's just one thing
that I got to say
Won't let another moment
slip away I hold on"
[guitar]
Thanks, ya'll.
[applause]
>>presenter: All right.
So, Michael, it looks like we
have one more question here
and for those of
you in the audience,
if anybody has
any last questions,
feel free to queue up
behind one of the microphones.
So, this last question
here comes from Suze
in Mountain View.
[reads question]
"Michael, your website promotes
health, fitness,
and organizations.
Can you tell us about how
this and events like Power
to the Peaceful happen?
Do you take the ideas
and turn them into,
how do you take the
ideas and turn them
into meaningful action?"
>>Franti: The
first part of the question,
yeah, on our website we
want it to be a place
where people come and don't
just check out our music,
or look at when
our tour dates are.
We want it to be a place
where there's a community
that can hang out
and that can connect.
Cause that's really
what our fans do.
They travel to a lot of
different shows
and our fans rage,
rage in age, haha.
They do rage in age.
[laughter] From like, little
kids, you know, to their moms.
And then 20 and 20-, you
know, college age kids
and then on up to like, 40
and 50 and 60 year olds,
so there's, there's like a
really wide range of people.
So, we want our
site to be broad;
issues that would be broad.
So we do have like a health
part of our site, a fitness.
We promote a lot of different
social justice organizations
and environmental
organizations and
every year we do this big
festival in San Francisco
called The Power to the
Peaceful and it started off --
[audience claps]
Yeah. It started off being a day
that we did on
September 11th, 1999.
And it was a day of ardent
action that 150 different
artists around the world did
different events for this man
named Mumia Abu-Jamal who's
on Death Row in Pennsylvania.
We felt like his case
deserved to be reheard
and so we selected the day 9/11
because we wanted to say
this is an emergency.
So, we put this on in 1999,
and then again in 2000,
and then 2001, of course,
the attacks occurred
on September 11th.
So, we wanted this day,
or the festival kind of
took a shift on that day
and we said, "We want this
day to be remembered
not as a day to
beat the drums of war.
We want our sadness
and our mourning to
be something more meaningful.
We want it to be a
day when we say,
'How can each of us do
something to make the world a
better place, a more prosperous
place for more people?'"
And, and so that's what
the festival became,
became a day where
we invite hundreds of
different social justice and
environmental organizations
out to the park
in San Francisco,
bring a lot of great
music, a lot of great food,
have activities for
kids and families,
and we do this giant free
concert for 50,000 people.
And the last part of
the question says,
"How do you take ideas and
turn them into meaning action?"
And people ask me a lot,
they say, "What can I do?"
And the best response
that I have come up with is,
"Do what you can."
And what I mean by
that is I met a woman
in Denver a few years back.
She said, "You know, Michael, I
saw your film about going to
Iraq and I thought what can
I do to change the world?
I'm a hairdresser."
And so what she did is she met
several women who were coming
because they were
having chemotherapy
and they were
losing their hair.
And so she decided to create
this one night every week
where she would do beauty
treatments, hair cutting,
whatever, for women who are
undergoing chemotherapy.
And I thought that
was just so incredible.
It's like, "What can I do?
Do what you can."
And so, that's
what we try to do is,
through our music and
through the events that we do,
is encourage people
to, to find ways that,
whatever it is that
your skill is to,
to give back, right?
>>presenter: So, we have
time for one more question.
>>membermale7: Should
I keep it short,
then? It's up to you?
>>Franti: Go ahead,
as long as you want.
>>membermale7: I, I was,
I wanted to ask you
a little bit about,
you mentioned before,
but how the economic models
for music has changed and,
and it seems like you're getting
paid more for performances
rather than the actual
production of the music now,
which means you kinda
have to keep touring,
keep performing
all the time.
It seems like once you
reach a large body of work
that people are listening
to all the time, that that
seems like something ideally
people would get paid for.
I don't know if you have
any feelings about that and,
and what the ideal
situation would be,
or if just that people
are accepting reality
and that's not gonna
happen any time soon.
>>Franti: I just think it's
a matter of time before
there's a model that worked out
so that every time a
piece of music is traded,
that it's somehow that
audio has actual audio,
is identified and that
every time it's traded,
that there could be some
way that there was a royalty.
I don't know if it's
through subscribership
or if it's through, you
know, some other means,
but I think that in the
future we're just gonna look
at this time as a little
bump in the road
in terms of the sale of music.
But, I'm not counting on that.
I'm, I'm just gonna continue
to go out and play music for
whoever wants to do it.
In part, because it's
how I earn my living,
but mainly because
it's what I love to do,
you know?
And so, I think that, I mean,
we, we do a lot of other
stuff, so we find ways to;
find hard things
that we could sell,
like children's books.
I just opened a yoga retreat
center in Bali that combines,
you know, my music and yoga,
which is another one of
my passions and we have an
organic clothing company that
does clothes that are beyond
just our regular tour t-shirts.
>>membermale7: Sure.
>>Franti: And so, we're
always trying to find ways
that we can be enterprising
to keep it all afloat
and most of the time we're
going hand to mouth,
but that's better than
going hand to no mouth.
[Franti laughs]
[audience laughs]
So, I feel really hopeful.
I feel more optimistic about
music today than ever before
and the reason for that is that
I remember that
when I was a kid,
everybody had like the 10 or 15
records in their collection
that they loved and then
when it turned to CDs,
everybody had like,
40 or 50 CDs
on one of those really cool,
black racks, you know?
[female laughter] Like, from
Sharper Image or something,
you know?
[audience laughs] And now, you
have whatever handheld device,
be it your phone or your i-,
iPod, or whatever it is
and you have thousands and
thousands of songs available.
And next, those songs
are gonna be somewhere,
like in outer space on
a cloud, you know?
[laughter] And all you
gotta do is just request it,
and it's there
for you, you know?
And you can have millions
of songs at your disposal,
and so I feel like the
more access to music,
the better it is for artists.
And the artists of the
21st century have to
become an artist who doesn't
just know how to play guitar,
but you know how to use
Facebook and social networking
and you understand
how you can make money
beyond just selling
a piece of plastic.
And as far as I'm concerned,
the sooner those plastic things
go away, the better, so.
>>membermale7: On the
hand to mouth question,
you still eating
red beans and rice?
>>Franti: I do--
[audience laughs] I still
eat red beans and rice.
It's my favorite thing.
[applause]
>>presenter: All right.
Michael, Thank you
for a very awesome show.
Let's close with one song.
>>Franti: Alright, cool.
Let's tune this guitar.
This is a song -- I mentioned
Woody Harrelson earlier --
this is a song I wrote
in Woody's bathroom.
[laughter] And Woody invited me
to his house 'cause he was off
makin' a movie somewhere and
we've been buddies for awhile
and he said, "You know,
you're recording in LA,
you should just hang out at my
house 'cause it's empty and,
and so I was in the
shower at Woody's house
and I put some guitar
chords down on my iPod
and I was playing
them back in the shower
and I started getting
this great idea.
And you know when
you have a great idea,
you have to write
it down somewhere,
you know?
You have to like, put it
on something and I, I, I,
I was inspired just going
in the bathroom here today
because there's all these great
ideas up in the bathroom--
[laughter] and I think that
it's a really great thing to,
actually, is like, if
you have an idea,
that there should be a space
that you could write it down
wherever you were so that
when other people came by,
that they could maybe
add something to that,
or, or it could
inspire them in some way.
So, Woody has this
great space in his,
in his shower and
I got this idea.
It was flowing, you know, and
I was like vibing off Woody's
energy there, man, and,--
[laughter] and I get this idea
and I go, "I gotta
write this down,
so I look all over
and I can't find a pen
and I looked everywhere.
And so, I get this idea like,
Oh, I know, I'll
just put it on the,
on the glass in the, on the,
on the shower and so like,
Hey, I got that one licked.
I write it all, I write
this whole song down
and then I get out of the
shower and I turn around
and the glass is
just evaporating.
And so I panic and I pick up
my iPod and I take a picture.
I'm like, "Click.
Technology delivers."
[laughter] I'm
feeling really, you know,
techy at the time, and then
I put it into Photoshop
and of course, it's
inside out and backwards
and I have to call my
friend back home to
walk me through
flipping the picture,
which for me was like
trying to land a 747--
[laughter] on like a piece of
ice in the middle of the ocean.
And so, I get it turned inside
out and backwards right way,
and I, I read the lyrics
and I'm like feeling,
"oh, this is great, like
a hit song, you know?
I think I wrote," and so I'm
sitting on Woody's toilet
and he calls and he's like,
"Michael, how's, how's, how's
the song writing going?"
And I'm like, "Woody,
its going great, man.
I think I wrote a hit
song in your bathroom."
[laughter] And he says, "Is
it a number 1 or a number 2?"
[laughter and clapping]
So, this is a song.
In, in 23 years we
had never had a song
in the top 20,000 before
until this song.
And this song actually made
it into the Top 20 last year
and if you know it, sing
along. It goes like this:
[sings] "I say hey
I'll be gone today
But I'll be back
coming around the way
It seems like everywhere I go
The more I see
The less I know
But I know one thing
That I love you, I love you,
I love you, I love you
One, two, put your
hands together, ya'll
[guitar]
I say hey, I'll be gone today
But I'll be back
coming around the way
It seems like everywhere I go
The more I see
The less I know
But I know one thing
That I love you,
baby girl I love you I love you
Make some noise
I've been a lot of
places all around the way
I've seen a lot joy and
I've seen a lot of pain
But I don't want to write a
love song for the world,
I just want to write a
song about a boy and a girl
Junkies on the corner
always callin' my name
And the kids on the
corner playin' ghetto games
When I saw you getting
down well I hoped it was you
And when I looked into
your eyes I knew it was true
I say Hey I'll be gone today
But I'll be back
comin' around the way
It seems like everywhere I go
The more I see
The less I know
But I know one thing
That I love you,
baby girl I love you I
love you I love you"
We need some more
kids up here.
Come on up.
You, too, in the
tie-dye shirt.
Come on up.
[guitar]
There we go.
"Now I'm not a highly
metaphysical man
But I know when the
stars are aligned you can
Bump into a person in
the middle of the road
Look into their eyes
and you suddenly know
Rockin' in the dance
hall movin' with you
Dancin' in the night
in the middle of June
My momma told me don't lose you
'Cause the best
luck I had was you
I said Hey I'll be gone today
But I'll be back
comin' around the way
Seems like everywhere I go
The more I see
the less I know
>>Franti: But I know
>>Jolene: I know
>>Franti: one thing
That I love you,
baby girl,
I love you, I love you"
Everybody on your feet now.
Everybody on your feet.
"Rockin' in the dance
hall movin' with you
I said Hey momma hey
momma close to you
Rockin' in the dance
hall movin' with you
Hey papa, hey papa
pick up your shoes
Rockin' in the dance
hall movin' with you
Hey Momma, hey momma
close to you
Rocking in the dance
hall moving with you
I said Hey momma, hey momma,
hey momma, hey momma
Hey momma, hey momma,
hey momma, hey momma"
[applause]
>>Franti: C'mon up here.
I wanna sing with me.
[pause]
[guitar]
Ok, that's ok.
>>Ade: "My momma told
me don't lose you
Cause the best
luck I had was you
I love you,
I love you, I love you"
[guitar] One, two, put
your hands up high!
Singin' hey, I'll be gone today
But I'll be back
coming around the way
Seems like everywhere I go
The more I see
the less I know
I said hey I'll be gone today
But I'll be back
coming around the way
It seems like everywhere I go
The more I see
the less I know
But I know one thing
that I love you,
baby girl I love
you I love you"
Jake, boogie rock that
guitar hard man!
[guitar solo]
Give it up for Jake
Boogie on the guitar.
"Hey, I'll be gone today
But I'll be back
comin' around the way
It seems
like everywhere I go
The more I see
the less I know
>>Franti: But I know one
thing
>>Audience: that I love you
Google, that I love you!"
[guitar]
[applause]
I wanna see you all jumpin'
One, two, three, come on, ya'll
[fast guitar playing]
>>Audience: I love you
>>Franti: I love you,
I love you,
I love you, I love you,
it's true, it's true,
I love you, I love you"
Google thanks so much
for having us here.
This is Jolene on the vocals,
Jake Boogie on the guitar.
My son, Ade.
I'm Michael Franti,
thanks so much,
I learned a lot here today.
Thanks a lot for havin' us here
and thanks for all
your support.
We love you!
[heavy guitar strumming]
[applause]
Feel it, feel it!
Thanks, ya'll.
[applause]
00:47:38.700,00:00:00.000
['Shake it' song
plays in background]